نبدا من الكويت وخبر عن عمليات غش منظمه
قالبه الدنيا وممكن حتى نسميها بصراحه
اضخم عمليه غش يمكن في التاريخ ما ادري بس
انه اكيد من الاضخم احنا بنتكلم عن غش صار
في الامتحانات الثانويه العامه متورط فيها
او في هذه العمليه 40,000 طالب والعصابات
المسؤوله عن الغش جمعت من وراءها ثلاثه
ملايين دينار كويتي يعني عشره مليون دولار
الكلام عن عمليات الغش هذه ترى من فتره
وشوفنا ايش معنى اخبار عنها كثير لكن
الجديد اليوم هو انه في مجلس الامن او في
مجلس همم الامه اخذوا وقفه من الموضوع
وطالب 10 منهم بعقد جلسه خاصه في الاول من
فبراير لمناقشه ظاهره الغش في المدارس
وتسريب اسئله الامتحانات اللي صارت خلال
امتحانات الثانويه العامه وراح يتم خلال
الجلسه مناقشه الحلول اللازمه لمحاربه هذه
الظاهره وتقديم بياناتها عن الا
والاحصائيات حولها وراح يتكلموا كمان عن
اتهامات للمدارس خاصه بالطورط في الغش
لرفع النتائج المدرسه طيب اللي صار خلال
الامتحانات الثانويه العامه زي ما قلنا
يعني تابع كل الكويتيين اخباره وشفنا كلام
عن تسريب الاسئله الامتحانات عبر جروبات
على الواتساب باسماء وهميه للطلاب وبارقام
مقيمين بنغاليين وعبره سماعات خاصه
بيلبسها الطلاب خلال الامتحان حتى وقت
الامتحانات في طلاب نقلوا للمستشفيات
وطلعوا من اذنهم سماعات دقيقه بيغشوا من
خلالها وفي اخبار كمان
بنفسهم ما شاء الله بيساعدوا اولادهم على
الغش وسائل الاعلام كويتيه قالت نقلا عن
مصدر من النيابه العامه انه في 20 متهم او
في 20 متهم في هذه القضيه بيتم ملاحقتهم
ورح يتم اتخاذ الاجراءات القانونيه بحقهم
اما وزاره التربيه فكانت اصدرت بيان في 26
الشهر قالت فيه انه ما راح تتوانا في
تطبيق كل القوانين اللي بتدعم العمليه
التعليميه ورحت حارب هذه الظاهره السلبيه
اللي بتصير خلال فتره الامتحانات مع
الجهاد المعنيه وكمان كانت الوزاره اصدرت
بيان امس قالت في ان مستمره بمحاربه ظاهره
الغش وان هي تعاونت مع وزاره الداخليه
وعملت خطه عمل قبل فتره امتحانات الفصل
الدراسي الاول للتخلص من ظاهره الغش والحد
منها واكد انها ريحه الحاسب كل متورط مهما
كان منصبه الوظيفي وراحت تتخذ الاجراءات
القانونيه بحق الطلاب اللي هتلبس عليهم
تهمه الغش في الامتحانات
[موسيقى]